true age with
in some ways you know to be honest like
with money in film I at least for me
like I've always found like I've been
more creative when I've had no money
either when I had a lot of money or no
money or in debt then when I have just a
little bit of money say if I had ten
thousand dollars at the time that I was
going to do the cards I would have
worried about spending it you know what
I mean gosh do I spend 10,000 Alec I
don't have nothing you know times can
actually for me at least it can be it
frees me up you know I'm not worrying
about what I'm losing I'm thinking only
about possibly to move forward you said
there were personal reasons for making
it i mean what was your ultimate goal
with it was adjust of a personal journey
that you wanted to kind of challenge
yourself or you had money making ideas
behind it i mean i guess like any
filmmaker you hope your comes ahead and
i believe but some can be it can be
successful but know anything I think you
know with that as your main goal you're
likely to fall short time in the outside
world this is about when they're in Iraq
war was going to start and I think like
a lot of people I felt that's a major
media wasn't really covering the war
very well and wasn't and it's just it
was a dark lonely time I think for like
for a lot of people really and then when
I saw the the government government had
put up this most wanted deck the Iraq
most wanted cards and I got saw copy
those and I just started laughing it was
like an idea that just kind of hit me a
Eureka moment was like hey I can make a
parody of these and they're there right
per card